I am a Solutions Architect for ppl just
going to run you through a little bit of
information about whose ppl what do we
do a bit of our data science journey
that we've just embarked on Delia is
going to walk you through the projects
that she's worked on we'll started
putting together for us and then just a
little bit about our plans for the
future so ppl we are a licensed music
licensing company established in 1934 we
exist to ensure that those who make
music are basically paid fairly for
their work we license recorded music
that's played in public so we deal with
bars shops radio TV broadcasters of that
we gather up that licensing revenue and
we work on getting that distributed back
out to our performer and right shoulder
members so what does that actually mean
why is that interesting well what we
actually do day to day when it comes
down to it is that we are a data
business while our revenue comes from
licensing music we don't have any
physical product that we sell we don't
deal with digital assets or anything
like that what we really do is we store
and manage large amounts of metadata so
we have data for our 90,000 members made
up of rights holders and performers
these members they really are the reason
that we exist as a company and they are
here to make music and we are licensing
that music that they have so we have a
repertoire database with over 10 million
recordings growing every day and again
once that we don't have all the audio
although we're thinking of
moving in that direction in the future
but we hold a lot of metadata
information that I'll go into a bit
further after we license that music out
to a huge number of broadcasters lots of
shops hairdressers nightclubs all of
that perhaps 380,000 public performance
venues and then we also have a lot of
reciprocal agreements with music
licensing companies around the world
whereby we protect their repertoire for
them and they protect ours for us so why
did we decide that we wanted to embark
down a path of data science a lot of the
reasons for us wanting to get involved
in this are going to be familiar there
are a lot of the reasons that drive all
the companies around we have large large
data volumes not as large as everyone
but certainly for us they're continuing
to grow and we have to do a lot of data
quality work on all of this data so I've
talked about our repertoire ok it's it's
about 11 million recordings at the
moment not crazy numbers but we received
nine hundred and nineteen thousand
recordings so far this year so that's
about seven and a half thousand
recording today and that's up from last
year where we were receiving four and a
half thousand recordings a day so the
rate at which data is coming in is just
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
with streaming with lower barriers to
entry
anyone can make a recording in their
bedroom they're all registering them
everybody wants to get out there get a
stream get a play and it just means that
in order for us to keep up it's going
absolutely crazy and we have to be more
efficient with the way that we work and
so we're addressing these problems of
high volume low value so I'm just trying
to figure out how the earth have a whole
computer thing works
yeah so almost all of the data that we
hold at PPL it's a very heavily skewed
long-tailed distribution you know we
have Adele we have ed Sheeran and they
earn a huge amount of money but you
could see we have 60,000 performer
members and the vast majority of them
are not earning adele money this we can
compare across our recordings as well we
have generally members of my head yeah
so the top 5% of our recordings
generally earn 90% of the money and then
we have a very long long tail of low
value recordings and I say low value you
know we're coming at this from a kind of
commercial sense but the people that
made those recordings the people that
played on those recordings even if
they're only earning 5 pound 1 pound 50
P that still matters to those people and
they're still our members and we're very
keen to make sure we can do the best
that we can do with all of that and
efficiency we are looking to be as
efficient as possible so all
organizations want to do this but
particularly at PPL we behave like a
commercial organization but at the heart
of it we are a member organization we
are owned by our members and we do not
retain any kind of profit so every bit
of money that we get in we pay back out
this means the more money we spend on
trying to improve the accuracy of our
data is ultimately money that we're not
paying out to our members so we've
always got that delicate balance of
trying to get it as correct as possible
for them so they get their money but
also making sure we don't spend all of
their money in the process so where do
we start we've decided we have a bunch
of data we want to work better with it
we want to work smarter get ourselves a
data scientist
great what are we going to do that so if
we take one of our not one of our basic
pieces of data our recordings they're
quite central to a lot of what we do I'm
going to just show a very basic example
of a simple recording simple data
looking nice so you've got a Beatles
song here hard day's night we're going
to spill information like the title
we've got the name of the band The
Beatles we have a recording date there
will be other information at that sort
of level of granularity where was it
recorded what country what country
commissioned it that type of thing we
also include the relationship between a
recording and one of our right shoulder
members so the Beatles of their
repertoire is currently owned by
Universal Music Group that's a very
simple example
you know rights can be quite complicated
people buy and sell them they start for
different periods they cover different
types of views but at a basic level
that's the kind of thing we're looking
at and then we're very interested in the
lineup the performers who is it who
performed on these recordings so in many
ways for a lot of people they think it's
quite simple well who is in that band we
know we all know who's in the Beatles
right just put whoever's and the Beatles
on the recordings pay them and we're
done but the reality is even than this
very simple scenario trying to remember
actually John Lennon is featured that
relates to the contract that he has with
the record company his feature then he
does vocals also guitar paul mccartney
vocals and bass and you get through the
beatles and then you get down to the
bottom and you realize actually hard
day's night had a little funky little
piano solo on there that was actually
played by George Martin
often known as the fifth Beatle and
their producer because he's not an
actual contracted member of the Beatles
we have to identify his sort of
performance differently as a non
featured this is a reason of well this
is about as simple as it gets for the
structure of the data we also have to
deal with the fact that we have these
ten eleven million recordings and we
want to get as close to that full
correct data for all of them because
without this data we're unable to
actually get the money from the people
who have paid to use it on the radio on
TV all the way out to the people who
played and made that music so what are
the types of challenging example do we
have orchestras orchestras have huge
memberships they have changing lineups
over time you know one year of violinist
is in another year they're out
conductors are changing different
soloists and trying to keep track of
that over time sometimes one section
will be on one recording that they're
not on another we have session musicians
just to give one example there's a
session player who no one will have
heard of I certainly hadn't before I
joined a ppl but she's played viola on
over 12,000 recordings in our database
for 1600 different artists some of those
covering take that Amy Winehouse Pet
Shop Boys York Fat Boy slim that's not
something typical that you would expect
that's a completely different type of
challenge to understand where where is
this type of performer going to turn up
and how can we make sure they are where
they should be
another challenging area of our data
sampling you know once somebody samples
a record and puts it onto theirs from
our perspective all the people that
played on the original sample they are
now on the new recording so from our
perspective there now performers on the
new recording so that's a whole path
that you have to track back through
understand who they are how are we going
to get them on there at the moment with
our policy decisions we go with the
whole song it yeah keeps it a bit
simpler so that's a fairly broad problem
how are we going to approach that how
are we approaching this problem to try
to move forward and use some of these
data science techniques our represent
our repertoire data comes from a variety
of sources
so we're owned by our membership and our
membership own the repertoire therefore
they supply it to us and we get varying
degrees of quality and completeness of
this data researching line up
information can be very very
labor-intensive a lot of the people in
the team will take similar approaches to
what most of you would they'll go in
they'll google it head off to Wikipedia
see who is in the band there are various
other crowd-sourced databases on the
internet and then we also have a lot of
specialist knowledge so people who
happen to know a vast amount about
classical music people who have contacts
within the music industry are able to
phone up a manager and say hey what
would be a session bass player you got
in on that track we're really trying to
complete the lineup here
so we decided we wanted to build a
recommendation engine to really increase
the efficiency of these teams but we
have doing our data quality works we
wanted to use analytics to assist them
to be more productive to automate the
work that could be easily automated and
to free up their time to be able to
focus on what they are good at they are
things that an algorithm is going to do
much much better than a guy who has a
load of music industry contacts and
there's a guy with a lot of contacts who
can do things that an algorithm just
can't do so obviously we're going to
apply some technology to this I'm a
Solutions Architect so great go through
the solution it got through the problem
what are we going to use to address this
we've got Python Python is great when
we're looking at our data quality in
this situation whilst I'm talking
numbers like 10 million recordings
ultimately what we're doing is we're
doing a lot of comparison throughout
that so while 10 million may not sound a
lot once you start to do Cartesian joins
on all that data back onto itself to
compare all the way across actually now
you're starting to deal with quite large
volumes of data so we started using
spark in HDFS try and churn our way
through that data and then presentation
at the end we're using a bi product
called burst that we use to manage that
data pushed in to redshift and then
ultimately visualize it and push it back
that's the toolkit that I gave delgo our
data scientist and now she'll give you a
bit of an explanation about what she did
with it thanks Mike um can you everyone
hear me so just a little bit of
introduction i'm doga and i'm data
scientist at PPL this
for these I worked as a software
engineer but I've done data analysis for
over 10 years but this is something that
really excites me music and looking at
the quirks of the data I wanted to
present here because I know some of
these problems are common across all
types of companies some of these are
very specific and have to be kind of
bespoke and it's kind of my journey
through solving a particular problem so
what is the goal here which performers
are likely to have contributed to the
recording and that's basically the goal
of the recommendation engine so the
first intuitive solution that I thought
of was collaborative filtering of course
collaborative filtering take an example
of Amazon we don't observe all
preferences we just observe choices so
we want to recommend consumers who
didn't purchase certain products the
products that they similar similar
consumers purchase so applying it to
this problem performers who have
collaborated intensely they're likely to
be on each other's recordings so here
for example a and B are recordings
performer 1 and 2 have both featured on
it so you're likely to add performer 1
to recording C and then I thought that's
great that's easy
there were some difficulties with that
so when you come and sort of try to
apply your our algorithm with its
machine learning or just statistics you
come to learn that actually some of that
doesn't really apply so I'll give you an
example adult we all know who's cheered
interestingly with music there's no real
unique identifier of an intensity so as
an example with Adele there actually to
Adele there is French Adele and there's
British Adele so how do you make sure
that a song by Adele who is exactly on
it the second example is arm there's a
obviously you guys know hello but an
instrumental version of hello may not
actually feature adult as a verb
so even if we listeners identify that
song as by Adele we don't want really to
kind of infer assume that she's on it
continuing on my journey I came across
Black Sabbath and so well I knew Black
Sabbath before but so here is a
particular release called born-again and
say a new recording comes in called
Stonehenge it's on this release and we
want to make sure that we add cool
members of Black Sabbath to that
recording here's an example of good data
point and a bad data point so a good
data point
I'll just go line by line a good data
point will have the the title a bad data
point will actually have loads of
different irrelevant stuff in there so
it could say featuring someone like
Black Sabbath it could say what is the
version of that it could be instrumental
album LP so it's quite hard to sort of
uniquely match based on the title itself
the date the date is very very important
so the original the actual recording was
recorded in 1983 and that's by that time
all the Osborne has already left the
band so you want to make sure that the
data is correct so that you can add the
relevant people just a very quick one
while release release is basically a
product you can have many different
products so it's very non unique you can
have many misspellings like Black
Sabbath now this is a this is the reason
why collaborative filtering may not work
here we have many recordings where we
don't have lineup so who is exactly
similar to an empty set you want to make
sure they have a tool which you can
apply to all sorts of things using the
metadata and the interesting thing about
our data is that we have a huge number
of sources very noisy
and ability to kind of find patterns
within that pushes us to the limit the
underlying problem is of entity
disambiguation so you have actual rows
you have different aliases of Axl Rose
on the right you have sort of the first
image on Google for each of these
aliases so I don't know what Google does
but I don't think they have a unique
dictionary of old aliases of Axl Rose
and they probably don't because the
first image would be probably similarly
if that was the case it's a hard problem
but having access to metadata and
different data sources can actually help
you solve this problems a few more
challenges I encountered band membership
changes over time I mentioned there is
many times there are many times when
contributors are not there it's an empty
set finally we want to make sure that we
add everyone who is on that track we
don't want to have we don't want to miss
someone who is very relevant so
recommendation engine is not the only
tool we use third-party sources we also
support industry-wide standardizations
to make sure that actually when we
exchange data with many different
sources it comes in the format that we
want and we can analyze but I focus here
purely on the recommendation engine so
through this journey I found that
insights very quick sort of statistical
sort of summaries actually are very very
helpful before diving into designing the
product
so as I've seen names are very important
you want to make sure that a recording
metadata comes in and we want to be able
to identify that it's Black Sabbath in
order to do that I needed to create a
dictionary of real entities and there
are aliases so in order to do that you
need to normalize the names whether it's
a recording title whether it's a band
artist name and in order to do that you
need to be able to kind of identify
pattern and one of the things that we
understood it early on is that there are
disconnected so these connectors can be
something like featuring with a KA this
kind of tokens that occur very commonly
and kind of signal that there is more
than one real entity in there but it's
difficult because you have certain
tokens that can be actually part of the
band name so Earth Wind and Fire is
actually a band and if you separate by a
comma and and you end up with three
entities so you want to make sure that
you can solve this problem what about so
the way I first it is have do they
actually sort of I created a very high
quality set of entities and I searched
whether any combination is within that
dictionary there is another problem that
happens which is above and beyond there
is a band called above and beyond
there's a band called above and there's
another band called beyond so how do you
make sure that you can get rid of that
so once I've sort of fought through
these problems um these are kind of very
music specific but I bet you know you
can probably apply these to many
different problems after that I try to
understand a little bit more about
Piper's and here I applied many
different techniques in tf-idf with
clustering fuzzy matching and what I
understood with names is that order of
the characters is very important so
fuzzy matching for me turned out to be
the best okay so
you know there are these stoplights but
you know when you're working with people
names that come from creative industries
they don't really have a limit to how
they can name so you have like banks
like check check check and when you get
rid of the punctuation it's just empty
so you want to you can't really have
proper stock swap words you can't have
get rid of anything in there that's
relevant
so once we've identified that that
recording was by Black Sabbath what do
we do now a bit of code on this is just
a function in Python that normalizes a
name very music specific so how do we
actually apply these in Spock so in
SPARC the first line is just saying hey
let's load the data there are two ways
in which you can apply that function so
one way is column wise the other is row
wise and it all depends on where you
want to do so just a very sort of quick
lesson here is that it's better to use
data frames because they are kind of
optimized already built in into SPARC
however they don't give you as much
flexibility as transforming the data
into RDD
I'm not going to go through this but I
will put these slides and these are some
of the lessons that I've learned through
using spark a lot of the performance
issues can be solved through
configurations and settings and actually
just doing this I was able to finish
everything all the fuzzy matching all
the recommendations within three to four
hours when it wasn't able to load as a
data scientist you want to be able to
visualize to see if your algorithm is
giving you some very obvious errors so I
use the tool called Goffe or the first
graph is basically I don't think you can
see it very well but you have clusters
the middle of the cluster is a band
parent so it's kind of the real entity
and branching off are the aliases so
here for example you will see the
biggest cluster is from Hungarian Czech
guy whose name is misspelled like
thousand times the right hand graph is
are actually collaborations between
different entities and you can also see
interestingly with Jeffie you can
automate the clustering so all these
there's a huge cluster here and when you
zoom in you'll be able to see that this
is actually all classical music so
without doing anything complicated you
can actually detect some interesting
clusters okay and I'm not sure if I have
time that um so now that we know it's by
black fibers who are the stable members
of Black Sabbath difficulty with that is
that date can sometimes be misreported
so in that example they were just so so
1970 83 track was miss reported as being
in 1979 how'd you get rid of that
problem the basic thing is outlier
detection
this doesn't get rid of all the problem
but it can get rid of a big chunk of the
problem
interestingly what you have outlier
detection in a kind of a creative
industry in the sense that each of the
bands and artists have their own
activity so sometimes you know career of
a musician is not as linear as you would
hope they can go off and do something
else come back so how do you within that
distribution detect outliers the first
thing I did was bootstrapping the
distribution finding out what is in the
top 5% what is in the bottom 5% but then
I realized you would be detecting kind
of out lights for every artist you want
to make sure that you cluster the
artists before you do that kind of
outlier detection okay so I sort of want
to go a bit more in detail but I don't
think I have time um once you identify
bands sort of proper activity you can
now start thinking about what is cool
member the first thing that came to my
mind when you think of a cool member of
a band is how long have they been in the
band but if you have very noisy data
it's very difficult to have kind of very
smooth transition and being able to
detect the duration of that person in
the band also remember you have remixes
remasters and all this stuff coming in
where the person may not be in there
what what did I do so for each year I
looked at the most common so the
performers who are in most tracks that's
kind of your second intuitive solution
is who is in most of the tracks
recording once you kind of detect core
member for that particular year you can
do that for every year and then you sort
of have a lineup for each year then what
I did was I clustered the year using on
as you probably all know
RSK done Python library and with
in that we have this really nice robust
clustering techniques DB scan so you can
kind of cluster years with similar
lineup when you do that you come across
this kind of problem where these are
different years and you have memberships
and you kind of have that problem where
you know you kind of see a break here
where you have a whole different members
membership of the band and you have sort
of like a in here but this B pops up
here can pop up here and you want to
kind of make sure that you're smoothing
that very well almost finishing with
that once you detect the Black Sabbath
main members I got this output so then I
can actually do the recommendation so
you know that was 1983 track so make
sure I am a butler
warden nickels are recommended to be
added just one more minute if I have we
are looking into this we're looking into
using graphs database and graph
processing so the next steps are from in
year four G per she spoke graphics and
these are some of the things that we can
do to capture very complex relationships
if you're interested in talking to me or
Mike at the end of the presentation or
later please feel free and I I would
love to have your suggestions
[Applause]
hi thank you that was a great tool and
love music and just one question can you
start bed sharing or more specifically
could you stop him for a Galway girl and
send a message to him you shouldn't get
any royalties for that is that possible
I'm afraid we are we only show up to
identify what's happened to make a
record of it and propagate out the truth
okay so you're not to blame well I'm not
unfortunately we just get the data in
and do what it tells us an interesting
case I think like some of the Sugababes
who started out and they've completely
change their lineup over the years and I
guess your your timeline technique would
would work for somebody like that it's
not right yes I should have sugarbabyz
and interesting example because this is
actually one of the first that we sort
of is very ban membership changing so
drastically over a year to year and it
you know we try to solve it to using
this clustering but obviously there are
so many things there that can go wrong
and you know it's it's an ongoing
problem you know and when you have a
meta data you want to make sure that you
can kind of assign what is the truth to
certain parts and unfortunately with
music data with any music data it's very
hard to know what is the truth so it's
kind of very hard for you to get to the
point to get the training data even it's
a very difficult problem so we're
working on it
just a minor comment and my question I
guess you don't take in the minor
comment is I guess you don't take it to
account you know Axl Rose replacing the
lead singer in ac/dc when they want and
tour cuz I guess he didn't do any
recording so that would be unnecessary
complication well until they come out
with a you know I've according record
exactly my question is do you find our
music brains useful their API and do you
have an API we don't have an API we're
still quite early on this and
musicbrainz is something that we brought
in while we were doing this work and we
had a look at that we've we found it
wasn't particularly useful in terms of
they don't have great lineup information
we've also been looking at discogs so
both of those rather than api's we've
downloaded their full data set and drop
them into RDS so you don't find their
unique ids useful if it was on a songs
or an artists it's something we're
continuing to look at there's definitely
something in it for helping us to
cluster and helping us identify the
actual entities it's still early days
for us there's just so much data out
there trying to get on top of it all is
that I think you also I add to that I
think discogs is doing a really good job
of crowdsourcing and we have been able
to detect some really interesting
patterns in discogs and through that
we're kind of going to another level of
you know trying to actually understand
the nature of collaborations and things
like that with all this metadata and so
discogs probably is a better source than
musicbrainz in my opinion thank you also
been looking at the Spotify API because
they do quite a good job of identifying
entities and collaborations you know
questions
[Applause]
[Music]